A lot of the time, it can be weirdly fun to
watch a terrible movie - especially when it's
so bad that it's actually kinda good.
Some movies, however, are so bad they're just
about unwatchable. Case in point?
Take a look at these irredeemable flops.
After the release of his stunning Holocaust
dramatic comedy Life is Beautiful, Roberto
Benigni was the toast of Italian cinema.
That movie took home three Oscars and made
millions of dollars at the box office in 1998
- which might just explain why he was given
the OK to film a live-action version of Pinocchio.
But it doesn't even come close to explaining
the movie he actually made.
Indeed, Benigni's remake was an all-out cinematic
disaster.
The reviews were brutal, the box office returns
were worse, and in a matter of days Benigni's
career in Hollywood was pretty much finished.
But this story does at least have kind of
a happy ending, as Benigni went on to play
Geppetto in the 2019 Italian adaptation of
the classic tale, which performed far better
with both critics and audiences.
The 2002 action flick Ballistic: Ecks vs.
Sever was arguably the first high-profile
zero-percent whiff in Rotten Tomatoes' then
four-year history—and rightfully so.
Even today, it's hard to imagine how a studio
actually spent $70 million on a convoluted,
far-fetched spy thriller starring Antonio
Banderas and Lucy Liu.
Either way, all that money didn't fool critics:
more than 100 of them panned the movie, landing
it quickly in Worst Movie Ever territory.
It's remained there ever since.
The original Highlander is a compelling contender
for the most enjoyable movie ever made; a
perfectly-tuned epic of '80s cheese, Queen
music, and swordfights.
Its sequel, however, is its polar opposite.
Think of it like the cinematic equivalent
of a stage performer accomplishing an incredible
magic trick and then immediately falling down
a trapdoor.
"There can be only one."
Right from the bizarre sci-fi-themed intro
cards, it's clear that something went very
wrong during the conception of this sequel.
For this movie, the genuinely intriguing concept
of a group of immortals walking the planet
since the dawn of time has been twisted into
limp speculative fiction about Earth's future.
Even worse, the immortals are revealed not
to be an offshoot of humanity, but rather
a race of aliens from the desert planet Zeist,
directly contradicting the original's entire
mythology - within the first ten minutes.
The result is a movie that pleases nobody;
a betrayal for loyal fans that's still too
weird for newcomers.
Within days of its limited theatrical release,
the John Travolta-led John Gotti biopic Gotti
was being confidently hailed as "the worst
mob movie of all time."
While it's hard to be 100 percent certain
if that's actually the case, it's hard to
see how things could get much worse.
Gotti's greatest sin is that it's incredibly
boring.
Aside from a few moments of unintended hilarity,
there's just not that much to enjoy.
Bizarrely edited and incredibly difficult
to follow, the movie is essentially a long
collection of technically uninteresting scenes,
stitched together with voiceover and real-life
archival news footage into something that
only sometimes looks like a film.
If Gotti ends up being remembered at all,
it will likely be due only to the movie's
pugilistic and manipulative marketing tactics.
In an effort to combat its 0 percent favorability
among critics, producers of the film rolled
out an ad campaign spuriously claiming that
it's not a movie for critics at all, but rather
something the general public would enjoy.
And that's fair - if you generally don't think
about movies, talk about movies, or watch
movies, then sure, you might be tricked into
believing this movie is fine.
As for everybody else - stay far away.
Capiche?
Here's the thing about Rotten Tomatoes: movies
that acquire a 0 percent fresh rating aren't
necessarily the worst movies in the world.
They're all bad to some extent, but they can
just as easily be aggressively average, too.
Stratton is one such movie: Boring and uninspired,
sure, but hey - it's probably not going to
kill anybody, either.
Coming from the director of Con Air and The
Expendables 2, Stratton is a by-the-numbers
action movie that never manages to elevate
itself in the way those semi-respectable adventures did.
The movie follows a government agency's quest
to stop a rogue former Soviet operative from
launching a chemical weapon attack on London.
And if that plotline sounds derivative, that's
because it is - and you'd better get used
to it, because there's not an original bone
in this movie's body.
Stratton's cardinal sin, however, is that
it brings together all those cliches and tired
tropes but forgets to throw in any actual
tension or excitement - and you kinda need
those in an action movie.
So sure, Stratton may not be the worst movie
ever made, but you'd still be hard-pressed
to find a single good reason to watch it.
Eli Roth's 2002 horror flick Cabin Fever is
far more notable for kicking off the filmmaker's
career than it is for its actual merits as
a movie; mostly because it has so few.
Somewhat obnoxious, gory, and sporadically
entertaining, it's the sort of middling movie
that could have really benefited from the
remake treatment, with another artist pulling
out its best assets while discarding the material
that just doesn't work.
But that's not what happened.
Instead, the 2016 version of the movie is
essentially the same film, just with worse
acting, worse casting, and even lower production
values.
Virtually every one of Cabin Fever's reviews
zeroed in on its utter pointlessness, critiquing
the movie on a fundamental level and questioning
its very reason to exist.
In a vacuum, this tale of a bunch of pretty
young people getting absolutely wrecked by
a flesh-eating virus probably wouldn't have
warranted such disdain - but considering the
movie's other crippling flaws, it's pretty
hard to know for sure.
Is there a movie star on Earth more obviously
bored with his career than Bruce Willis?
Once the very embodiment of the charismatic
everyman, Willis' most recent achievements
seem to have amounted to little more than
tanking the Die Hard franchise and refusing
to appear in The Expendables 3.
But while Willis' more recent projects haven't
exactly been great, it's rare that his movies
get as devastatingly dull as 2016's Precious
Cargo.
Writing for RogerEbert.com, the critic Peter
Sobczynski described this action movie as
a "VOD craptacular" that is basically as forgettable
as they come.
It's a film completely incapable of transporting
the viewer into its world, leaving you constantly
aware that you're watching actors who are
simply going through the motions.
They drive speedboats, they shoot guns, they
collect paychecks.
There's no artistry here - you know it, the
filmmakers know it, and Bruce Willis clearly
knows it more than anyone.
If he had just played up to the movie's badness,
Nic Cage style, Willis might have been able
to make Precious Cargo just a little more
entertaining; instead, he looks annoyed to
even have to be there.
Still, in that sense at least, it's probably
his most relatable performance in years.
Unfortunately, Simon Sez isn't a movie adaptation
of the hit light-up game - although even watching
a Simon toy light up for an hour and a half
would probably be more entertaining than this
dire Dennis Rodman sequel.
The original movie, Double Team, featured
the bad boy basketball player and Jean-Claude
Van Damme teaming up to kick butt and act
badly.
"Yaz, behind you!"
"Oh, shh-"
Van Damme didn't return for the sequel, however,
so they got the next best thing: Dane Cook.
As such, the movie is filled to the brim with
so-called "comedy," alongside a bunch of shots
of Rodman trying to look cool while things
blow up in the background.
So, yeah, it's bad.
But it at least serves as an amusing reminder
that Dennis Rodman actually used to be a pretty
big deal… a long, long time ago.
If you watched the fourth season of Project
Greenlight, The Leisure Class may as well
have been called Schadenfreude: The Movie.
In the reality show about a contest winner
getting a chance to make their own film, Ben
Affleck and Matt Damon picked the supremely
obnoxious Jason Mann as their champion.
The Leisure Class was the result - a comedy
where nothing funny happens, the characters
inexplicably change on a whim, and even the
basic story doesn't really make any sense.
On the surface, it's a good idea for a film:
a con man falls in love with his mark only
to have his ne'er-do-well brother come in
at the last minute to mess everything up.
But the tone changes wildly from scene to
scene, the lead is shockingly stiff, and it
even looks horrible.
It's truly hard to find anything good about
The Leisure Class, which is why it's so delightful to watch.
Seeing an arrogant kid like Mann get his comeuppance
in more-or-less real time is more satisfying
than you can possibly imagine.
When the sitcom Friends became a hit for NBC
in 1994, Hollywood quickly signed up its six
young and funny cast members to headline a
number of feature films.
For the most part, these movies were forgettable,
middling romantic comedies, like David Schwimmer's
The Pallbearer or Matthew Perry's Fools Rush
In.
These movies were nothing special, but they
weren't exactly horrible, either.
And then there's Ed, the 1996 sports comedy
starring Matt LeBlanc opposite… a rowdy chimpanzee.
LeBlanc plays Jack "Deuce" Cooper, a talented
baseball pitcher who chokes under pressure
so much that he's relegated to an obscure
minor league team.
Even more humiliating: the team's third baseman
is its former mascot, a primate named Ed.
Over the course of the movie, Deuce learns
to believe in himself and how to be a good
friend, all because of that wacky chimp with
a heart of gold.
Not only was Ed a box office bomb, bringing
in a grand total of $4.4 million, but critics
were united in their utter hatred for the
movie.
For example, Dasson Thomson of the Washington
Post called it:
"Breathtakingly unadventurous, with its cheesy
story line, hackneyed ballpark-fable sentiments,
'adorable' animal, and collection of one-dimensional
human nincompoops."
In the early 1980s, Chuck Norris was the king
of a certain kind of patriotic war movie,
in which the star could bomb, shoot, and karate
kick bad guys to his heart's content.
The success of Missing in Action and The Delta
Force would eventually lead to Norris playing
a mystical, kick-happy lawman on the '90s
action show Walker, Texas Ranger.
This then led to a revival of his film career,
which by then had taken a bit of a downward turn.
This was largely because Norris' style of
movie had grown a little passé - so filmmakers
tried to open things up by sticking him in
a family comedy.
The result is Top Dog, in which Norris plays
a loose-cannon cop who gets teamed up with
a super-smart police canine.
Top Dog is supposed to appeal to kids, but
it's also casually and extremely violent,
following a plot about extremist terror attacks.
Critics loathed the movie, too, which wound
up with a 0 percent on Rotten Tomatoes.
As Roger Ebert asked in his Chicago Sun-Times
review:
"Why, exactly, would you want to make a movie
about racist hate groups, and then disguise
it as family entertainment about a cute dog?"
Launched to stardom in the late 1980s with
the movie I'm Gonna Git You Sucka and then
in the '90s with the sketch comedy series
In Living Color, filmmaker and actor Keenen
Ivory Wayans struggled to find a follow-up
project that was a good match for his talents.
His two stabs at action heroism - Most Wanted
and The Glimmer Man - both bombed… but at
least critics had a few nice things to say
about those movies.
The same can't be said for Wayans' 1994 romantic
action comedy A Low Down Dirty Shame.
Wayans wrote and directed the oddly laid-back
movie about Andre Shame, a disgraced police
detective and private eye who just can't seem
to bust drug kingpin Mendoza.
Suddenly, Shame finds a new lead, and gets
back on the case with the help of his sassy assistant "Peaches."
Austin Chronicle critic Alison Macor summed
up the movie best, writing:
"I'm not sure what type of movie this is supposed
to be or who its audience is, but it's a low
down dirty shame that Wayans' talent is wasted
on this film."
Some of the movies that have tried and failed
to reach the critical and box office highs
of the original Jaws include Deep Blue Sea,
the many Sharknado movies, and Jaws' own sequels.
"You're gonna need a bigger boat."
Making a movie like this is like walking a
tightrope over a proverbial shark tank - if
it's too violent, salacious, or gory then
it's an outright bad movie.
If it goes too far in the other direction,
instead focusing on tension and dread, then
it's usually perceived as little more than
a Jaws rip-off.
Somehow, Dark Tide manages to be both.
Halle Berry plays a shark expert and diving
teacher who has to guide a daredevil rich
guy into a part of the ocean so infested with
sharks that it's nicknamed "Shark Alley."
You can probably guess what happens next.
As Peter Bradshaw wrote in The Guardian:
"The sharks themselves are the only ones to
emerge with credit from this."
Hollywood foisted seven Police Academy movies
onto the world in the '80s and '90s, despite
only the first being a true blockbuster - and
all of them getting absolutely savaged by the critics.
As far as Rotten Tomatoes scores are concerned,
Police Academy is among the most critically
loathed and poorly reviewed franchises in
movie history.
Entries four through seven - Citizens on Patrol,
Assignment Miami Beach, City Under Siege,
and Mission to Moscow - are all rated at 0
percent on the site.
Operating under the premise that a big-city
police department has to sign up virtually
anyone who wishes to protect and serve, these
particular installments find the cadets training
new hires, traveling to Miami, fighting an
organized crime ring, and trying to take down
a money launderer in Moscow.
Ian Freer of Empire, in his review of Police
Academy 4: Citizens on Patrol, summed up the
thoughts of his fellow critics with regards
to the whole series.
He wrote:
"Oh dear... oh dear, oh dear..."
Tom Selleck got his movie career going in
1987 with the smash hit Three Men and a Baby.
Sadly, he didn't have many more hits beyond
that - although he did offer up a kind of
reversal on Three Men and a Baby with the
1992 comedy Folks!, in which he played a yuppie
trying to contend with his aging parents.
Supposedly a comedy, Folks! is basically a
nasty, 100-minute insult against well-meaning elderly people.
Selleck plays Jon, who invites his increasingly
infirm parents to move in with him and his
family after his father burns down their home.
However, his folks' meddling somehow causes
Selleck's character to lose his job - as well
as his wife and kids.
In his review for the Seattle Times, Michael
Upchurch wrote:
"The film's appeal will depend largely on
whether you feel like laughing at senile dementia."
And that about sums it up.
The D-grade E.T. ripoff Mac and Me is noteworthy
for just a few reasons.
Firstly, it contains perhaps the most egregious
use of product placement in Hollywood history,
with an entire scene being devoted to an amazing
birthday party held at McDonald's - that even
features Ronald McDonald himself.
It's also a dance number, which E.T. is notably
lacking, so at least Mac and Me brought something new to the table.
But that's about it.
Honestly, the only real reason anyone might
have to watch this silly '80s flick is to
get some context for a running gag Paul Rudd
has been doing for years.
Every time he guests on Conan O'Brien's show
to promote a film, he switches out the clip
of that film with the same clip from Mac and
Me.
"Eric, stop!"
He's been doing it for over ten years now,
and to his credit, it's actually a pretty
good bit - which is more than can be said
for the movie itself.
Stories about secret government conspiracies
were a big deal in the '90s.
Unfortunately, for every all-time great like
X-Files or Enemy of the State you had…
Well, you had something like Shadow Conspiracy.
Charlie Sheen, at the time a legitimate movie
star after the success of Platoon and Hot
Shots!, stars as Bobby Bishop, an innocent
and earnest presidential aide who discovers
a plot orchestrated by the White House Chief
of Staff to assassinate the Commander-in-Chief.
People get killed left and right as a result,
and it's up to Bobby and a plucky reporter
to put an end to the threat from within.
The problem is, Shadow Conspiracy isn't quite
as clever as it thinks it is.
According to Maitland McDonagh of TV Guide:
"Corpses pile up, dreadful secrets are uncovered,
and Bishop eventually gets to the bottom of
things, a full hour after the least attentive
viewer will have figured out who's behind it all."
In elementary school, millions of American
kids learn about the country's homegrown folklore
- 19th century "tall tales" about larger-than-life
figures like the lumberjack giant Paul Bunyan and John Henry.
In the tales, Henry is a Hulk-like, ultra-strong
railroad worker known as "the steel-driving man."
The 2020 movie John Henry, however, reimagines
the character as a tough, modern-day man who
uses his abilities to reluctantly right wrongs.
Terry Crews plays the titular John Henry,
who is trying to get over his violent past
when he runs afoul of his old crime boss after
helping two Honduran immigrants escape gang violence.
Movie critics weren't exactly moved by John
Henry, however, collectively bestowing it
with a 0 percent on Rotten Tomatoes.
Jeannette Catsoulis of the New York Times
said:
"No kindness goes unpunished in “John Henry,”
a thug-life thriller so frequently preposterous
that it almost resembles a parody."
While Michael Rechtshaffen of the Los Angeles
Times said:
"John Henry [...] lands with all the subtlety
of the mighty steel-driving man's sledgehammer."
Flash, fancy cars driven by a rogues' gallery
of cocky, tight-knit characters in a world
of underground street racing - those are the
elements that helped make the Fast and the
Furious franchise so irresistible and lucrative
to audiences around the world.
Obviously, the filmmakers behind Redline hoped
the market was big enough for another movie
of that ilk, only with less money and fewer
famous cast members.
Unfortunately, Redline grossed a paltry $8.2
million, largely because the vast majority
of the moviegoing public immediately recognized
it for what it was: a shameless, unabashed,
not-very-good ripoff of the Fast and Furious
saga.
Not convinced?
Check out this atrocious scene.
"Eric, stop!"
OK, we pulled a Rudd.
But critics loathed the real movie, which
currently sits at an impressive 0 percent on Rotten Tomatoes.
As J.R. Jones of the Chicago Reader so succinctly
explains:
"The whole thing is pretty stupid."
There are a lot of haunted house movies out
there, to say the least.
It's a tried and true film subgenre, and they
really do fill a niche, mostly because audiences
love the familiar beats of stories about things
that go bump in the night.
Now, movie critics traditionally aren't all
that keen on horror movies, but it's still
pretty hard to make one so bad that it's panned
by literally everybody.
But that's exactly what happened with The
Disappointments Room.
In this movie, a woman named Dana and her
family move out of busy Brooklyn in favor
of a house in the country.
It's already occupied, however, by secrets,
ghosts, and plenty of foreboding dread, all
thanks to the family that lived there in the
1800s.
Robert Abele of The Wrap said the movie consists
of "a litany of embarrassments," while Marc
Savlov of the Austin Chronicle wrote that:
"The Disappointments Room lives (and dies)
up to its name."
Conventional wisdom holds that there are two
kinds of successful movies: box office smashes
and critical darlings.
There actually isn't a lot of disparity between
the two - blockbusters are often praised by
critics, while award winners can get a serious
financial boost from their plaudits.
And the movies that critics hate often bomb
at the box office, too - after all, a dud is a dud.
But then there's Problem Child, a chaotic,
cynical, snotty, and somehow also sentimental
comedy with a 0 percent Rotten Tomatoes…
that made an absolute fortune at the box office.
John Ritter, a beloved TV star who couldn't
really get a legitimate movie career going,
plays sweet Ben, a man desperate to be a father
but unable to have one biologically.
So he adopts Junior, an almost demonically
bratty kid who makes life horrible for Ben.
As Dennis King of the Tulsa World wrote:
"It's misguided.
It's not funny.
And in its lame efforts to be irreverent and
hip, it turns out to be just plain mean."
As noted earlier, Bruce Willis made a name
for himself playing tough guys and reluctant
heroes in action movies during the 1980s and
1990s, a golden age for the genre.
It's been a long time since the release of
Die Hard or Armageddon, however, and filmgoers
have mostly moved on to other things.
But for a small but devoted audience who still
wants to see the sixty-something action icon
do his thing, he still makes a few low-budget
action flicks each year - all of which get
quietly dumped onto home video and streaming
platforms.
Hard Kill is an especially bad example of
these late-period Willis movies.
The story of hired guns trying to stop a supervillain
from using computers to cause worldwide chaos,
filming on this movie took place over just
10 days.
If nothing else, however, that means Hard
Kill managed to earn its 0 percent Rotten
Tomatoes score with the utmost efficiency.
London Fields actually starts out with an
intriguing premise: A psychic named Nicola
Six predicts that she is about to be killed.
Her sixth sense tells her that her killer
will be one of three men, so she starts an
affair with each in order to discover the
true circumstances of her death.
London Fields is based on a darkly comic,
critically-acclaimed 1989 novel by British
mystery author Martin Amis, but the adaptation
apparently failed to capture what was so special
about the book.
Peter Sobcyznski of RogerEbert.com said that
even viewers who know the novel well will
have a hard time following the convoluted
action of what amounts to "a boring and garish mess."
David Sexton of the London Evening Standard,
meanwhile, likened London Fields to "a music
video," while Jeannette Catsoulis of the New
York Times found it:
"Horrendous - a trashy tortured misfire from
beginning to end."
Still… it could have been worse.
"Eric, stop!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the best
and worst movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.